hello everybody my name is naya and i'm
the black female engineer i provide
content for new and inspiring software
engineers and today
we're talking about my coding bootcamp
regrets
things that looking back i do wish i had
done
differently when it comes to my
attendance at flat iron school
and how i proceeded throughout the 16
weeks the four months there
and so yeah let's just get to it for
those who don't know
i attended flatiron school in june of
2020 so june of 2020
to october of 2020 so pretty much
exactly last
year i'll add some links below talking
about my coding bootcamp experience
and just you know other videos related
to it
but for sake of not repeating myself
i'll just keep it at
that and really one of the biggest
things i regret
is how i didn't look up more scholarship
opportunities to attend coding bootcamp
whether it's fine arts school general
assembly
all of these different boot camps they
cost
a lot they cost a pretty penny
and for me how much is flat high school
flying school was
i think thousand dollars either fifteen
thousand
or eighteen thousand dollars and so
you know i don't just have that sitting
in my bank and
i had applied to a scholarship provided
by flat art school i believe it was
about
three thousand dollars worth which is i
think why i can't remember if it's
fifteen thousand dollars or eighteen
thousand dollars is the actual full
price of the boot camp
but i got that scholarship and i felt
pretty good
about it i felt pretty good i was okay
cool i just saved 3k
great so i didn't really have many
regrets in terms of money
until about a month or two months ago
when i was watching an instagram live
between
it's that lady dev and the natural
techie i'll link them down below
and the national techie was talking
about how she was basically able to get
a full
ride to attend general assembly after
doing some research and finding
scholarships and grants and basically
organizations who would pay for her
to make the switch to attend a boot camp
and so
i when i heard that my mind was blown my
mind
was blown i seriously just
i was like why did i not do this because
especially in this day and age there are
organizations and people looking to see
more
people of color and women in these tech
roles and so they will pay for you to
attend so
if you are in these groups if you are in
some type of minority group
take some time some real real time into
seeing
if you could get sponsored if you can
get funded get grants get scholarships
any which way to attend a boot camp
because
man i'm over here looking and
calculating how much i'm going to need
to pay
for the next couple of months not even a
couple months for the next like year to
two years
to pay off my debt and everything and of
course i
am grateful for everything finance
school did for me but oh my gosh
like fifteen thousand dollars fifteen
thousand dollars is a lot
so yes that's basically my biggest
regret was not putting more time into
seeing what scholarships and grants are
out there for
people like me my second boot camp
regret
is focusing on simply making it another
day
rather than the whole picture boot camp
is
so fast and so so much
it's so much information being thrown at
you in such a fast
rapid rate that my mind couldn't even
really think about the whole picture and
i was
constantly focusing on just surviving
until 5 p.m tomorrow
and that was my attitude the entire like
16 weeks
and i regret that looking back
because it definitely made me miss a lot
of things going on around me when i was
just so focused on you know this line of
code
and this assignment and this project now
i kind of got lost in it all not really
putting an emphasis on my
own self-professional development
and more just i can't get left behind
and all in all if you know my journey
and everything i was able to
secure a job pretty quickly after coding
bootcamp and i'll add links
to how i did that how you can do that
too below however
in terms of state of mind i don't
recommend that for
anyone that type of i don't even know
like i kind of think of it as like a
hunger games mentality of
i'm just trying to survive i can't even
think about
you know this field i'm in i can't even
think about the scenery because i'm just
trying
to get past this bear in front of me and
so
i really regret having that mindset
because it led me to
putting so much stress on myself and
really turning away
opportunities to learn other things
because i was like oh
it doesn't directly correlate to this
specific assignment and so i'm not even
going to
waste time on learning about like the
cloud or whatever
and so i really regret that because no
we're trying to
be well-rounded individuals we're trying
to just really gain
knowledge great experiences and just
develop professionally and
as aspiring and software engineers and
so
the way i went about it really didn't
help
with that mission and so if you're about
to attend a boot camp or
you are currently in one check yourself
a little bit ask yourself if that's
what you're doing and if so take some
time take an hour to
every day every other day every week to
learn
something different that doesn't
seemingly directly correlate to what
you have to learn from boot camp but
like it would still help you as a person
and i think that'll just help reframe
your mind and just help
with continuing on this journey my third
regret
if you knew me from the time of june
2020 to october 2020
you did not you did not know me i lived
and breathed flat iron that is all
i would let my mind think about that is
all
i would put time and effort towards that
and finding a job
afterwards which to me are also related
because that's why i'm at flatiron
but yeah you did not hear from me i was
i
was a ghost i was gone and i really
regret that because again
it led to this pressure
just weighing on me all the time that
the breakdowns
the breakdowns i had while attending
flatiron the
mental state i was in on the surface it
looked like
i had my ish together and i was
getting it but inside i i couldn't sleep
y'all i could not
sleep i couldn't allow myself to think
about anything else to
spend time with family and friends
because i was like if
you're it's what i'm trying to get a job
i'm trying to make this career switch
and quickly so
this doesn't serve that so off with you
and on one hand especially with hustle
culture
that can be seen as like a good thing
something to aspire to but that is not
me
at all i am not a hustle culture type of
person
if you knew me in college i definitely
was now
no not at all i believe in
well-roundedness
and putting time to the people and
things that bring you
joy that light the spark within you and
that's not always work and learning and
exercising sometimes
it's simply just being on the couch with
your friends watching i don't know the
bachelorette or something so
i really wish i had understood that
then instead of putting that much weight
on myself because again
it looked from the surface that i had it
all together
and i was getting it and everything but
i
was so unhealthy i was not sleeping
barely eating because i was like okay
i only have 30 minutes for lunch let me
run and just you know
get some chick-fil-a and then eat and
then i
can sleep at 3am after doing these five
extra hours of work
it was not good and so if you have this
mentality i'm not going to tell you what
to do
and everything but likely it is going to
lead to
your demise and in some capacity of just
you're going to just crash one day and
miss assignments or miss projects or
miss deadlines or now you can't look for
jobs because you're just so drained and
now you don't even like to code you know
what i mean like what if you now don't
even like to code because it has
caused this much stress and angst within
you and now you kind of resent it
and so that's a huge huge thing i regret
about my experience at flat iron was
my living and breathing of bladder and
number four
last but not least i really regret
having this kind of
chip off my shoulder it's kind of
embarrassing to even say out loud
i kind of had this chip on my shoulder
while at flatiron again
kind of with this hunger games mentality
of fight to the finish like
move out of my way i will blaze through
this and i will succeed and like
you can't touch me like i really regret
that
i was able to check myself on multiple
occasions and be like no nya this
let's all be friends let's everyone here
is trying to do the same thing
you are let's all be friends let's help
each other out and that definitely was
the mentality so don't get me wrong that
definitely was the mentality
with my campus at least in flatiron i
hear that there are different
experiences in different campuses and
different boot camps
but mine very much was a love bubble
we'd like to call it
but there were times in private where i
did have this chip on my shoulder of the
competition of like no
this person looks to be so much ahead of
me so like let me make sure to catch up
to them
rather than saying no i want to make
sure i want to
learn x y and z because that's my
passion so let me make sure i do what i
can
to get there do you see how these
mindsets
are different and one can very much be
healthier than the other and so i do
regret having that chip on my shoulder
at times but i'd say i was pretty good
at
checking myself so that one has like an
asterisk whenever i
felt myself getting into that mentality
of oh
like no no to everybody no
like competition competition whenever i
found myself in that mentality
i was able to check myself and kind of
reframe my mind a little bit but i just
don't like that i had to even check
myself because i was like girl like come
on let's
let's just learn and get it moving okay
and
go get your water go get your green tea
and everything get your eight hours of
rest
and do it all again tomorrow and let's
keep on keeping on now do i
regret going to a coding bootcamp i.e
flatiron school
i do not i do not regret it at all it
truly i think
is the best decision i've ever made to
be completely honest with you
i loved my time at flatiron i think
not even i think after talking with some
of y'all i
realized i was extremely blessed and
lucky
to have landed in the campus i did and
with the teachers and instructors i did
i have realized that i was given
resources
and other students and cohort mates
of my campus were given resources that
other campuses
even of the same exact school flat iron
school
just do not have and so if i was a part
of a different campus a different
boot camp i do believe that this would
be
a different conversation depending on
the campus and boot camp
however me i was a part of the denver
campus
it was fantastic fantastic
fantastic and so if anyone from there is
watching this
thank you so much for the dedication you
put into fostering this amazing
community because that's really
what made it so great was the community
of it like i said it was a love bubble
and so i don't regret it and away
from just it being a positive experience
because of the community
i mean of course it was rough it was
hard it was rough it was so much
information
and stressful and everything but the
community helps a lot
um and having a good community helps a
lot with
dealing with all those things but also
all of that aside
i was able to get an amazing job
after my attendance i got my first offer
the day of my boot camp graduation
and signed on an offer later that same
month so i
graduated october 2nd and i signed on an
offer october 29th
something like that october 29th and so
i am grateful for that
being able to make such a quick career
shift
i had graduated finance in may of 2020
in october of 2020 so what six
months ish something like that months
later now i was
an employed software engineer so like i
i am very grateful i'm very happy and
i hope this was informative i hope if
you're thinking about coding boot camp
or
you're currently in one you think about
some of these things as you continue
on your journey and just yeah put a
little checkpoints
in for yourself to make sure your mental
state and your well-being
is being taken care of and so thank you
so much don't forget to subscribe
like this video it helps me out so so
much but no
thank you so much and i'll see you all
later bye